[Music]
on january 19th the time had finally
come and we were able to watch the first
teaser for the new amazon series the
lord of the rings the rings of power
here of course accompanied by epic music
the logo of this series was forged
before her eyes so to speak and the
official title was revealed for the
first time
unfortunately teasers often don't show
scenes from the upcoming project but are
only meant to with the appetite for more
for this amazon released a brand new
teaser trailer at the super bowl last
sunday which of course will also come up
in our original we also talk about the
content the cast the production and
recent pictures so you'll be up to date
afterwards so watch carefully and have
fun with our latest original
first and foremost of course is the
question of the storyline as we already
know this series will not be a remake of
a previous story but will stand
completely on its own there will be
clear gap of about 3 000 years between
frodo's adventures and the upcoming
series which is why one can't speak of a
kind of prequel resourceful fans of the
franchise will know that we are thus in
the second age of middle-earth the most
important indication for this besides
the little information about the story
are a total of four maps of middle earth
published on twitter which also reveal
some hints about the setting for example
you can recognize the fortress minas
ethil which was taken in 2002 of the
third age and renamed minas morgul
another place marked on the map is minas
anor the capital of gondor which was
later renamed minas tirith and has
existed since the year 3220 in the
second age you can also see the small
island tophalas at the lower end of the
coast
it was destroyed after the numenoreans
were wiped out in the second age making
it barren and hilly as can also be seen
on the map if you look closely we've
also known about the official plot
details from amazon itself for quite
some time according to them the heroic
legend of the legendary second age will
be revived the series is supposed to
bring the view back to an era of great
powers falling and rising kingdoms and
unusual heroes and reveal the greatest
villain that ever came from tolkien's
pen
man is probably sauron although melkor
would probably object to that it follows
that the evil will grow strongly in a
time of peace and will have to deal with
an ensemble of old and new characters in
asian world last the whole map is to be
explored again there are a few theories
in this regard one of them is that we
can expect breathtaking open sea
adventures above all that's not unlikely
after all the island kingdom of numenor
is in the far south west of the map at a
point that only ships can reach by sea
the plot of the first of probably five
seasons will also be told in eight
episodes of still unknown length in the
teaser galadriel speaks the first lines
of tolkien's famous one ring poem it
says three rings for the elven kings
under the sky seven for the dwarf lords
and their halls of stone
nine for mortal man doomed to die
one for the dark lord on his dark throne
in the land of mordor where the shadows
lie
so far we only know the story of the one
ring from the movies but the series
wants to show us all of them in the
course of the story the children is jd
payne and patrick mckay have summarized
it quite well in the press release in
the series all the important stories of
the second age are told i.e the forging
of the rings sauron's path to power the
exciting story of numenor and then of
course the final alliance of elvis and
men which by the way is said to have
been one of the largest and most
glorious armies in the docking universe
also not to be neglected of course is
the cast at least three familiar roles
have already been officially confirmed
for the series on the one hand there's
the elf galadriel who will no longer be
portrayed by kate blanchet but by
morpher clark she's certainly one of the
most famous figures from middle earth
and now gets a significant rejuvenation
thanks to a 32 year old clark also
present are alron and of course the
villain sauron with elrond this time
being embodied by robert aramaio it is
also very likely that sauron as once in
the book will make use of his ability as
a shapeshifter one of these figures is
the character anatar who comes across as
very friendly but only serves the sole
purpose of convincing the elves to forge
his rings most of the casts consist of
relatively unknown faces they are for
example marcela cavanaugh who is to take
on the new character nori and joseph
maul who embodies the villanoran
meanwhile several dozen actors are known
but most of them haven't had any major
appearances yet
just as with peter jackson's trilogy
they chose beautiful new zealand as
filming location unfortunately as with
many other productions not everything
went smoothly due to the pandemic
filming had to be possible that up to
800 crew members were sent home and
production came to a standstill for
weeks for a project that is supposed to
cost over 1 billion us dollars as it is
this is of course no trifle fortunately
however production was resumed as soon
as possible and is still in full swing
by the way the large-scale project is
not filmed chronologically but very
efficiently with always several scenes
at one location of course it is only
possible if the script for season 1 is
finished because with this production
variant it is extremely difficult and
costly to reshoot scenes later season 2
however means saying goodbye to new
zealand because it will be produced in
great britain the responsible actors
behind the camera are on the one hand as
already mentioned johnny payne and
patrick mckay who both act as serious
developers and are the creative minds
behind the project the director
responsible for at least their first two
episodes was juan antonio bayonna known
from jurassic world in the subsequent
episodes wingnip and charlotte branstrom
will take their places in the director's
chair who definitely will not return as
peter jackson who refused to take a
leading position in the production he's
only to be available in an advisory role
what will also interest fans is the
budget which has already been hinted at
because calculated at 1 billion us
dollars the lord of the rings series
will become the most expensive series
production of all time the filming
rights alone are said to have cost 250
million us dollars not to mention the
huge budget for season 1 which is said
to be 465 million us dollars on the
other hand amazon will certainly receive
a nice sum from the new zealand
government because the streaming giant
is entitled to an estimated 116 million
us dollars from a national subsidy fund
due to the local jobs generated
[Music]
amazon's a true master of secrecy which
is why the rumor mill has a particularly
hard time finding valid information
however the streaming giant provided one
itself in the form of 23 pictures that
were posted at the beginning of february
discussing every single one in detail
will of course go beyond the scope but
there are at least a few clear pictures
that we don't want to withhold from you
first there's the image with a silver
and gold dagger and armor that alludes
to the dress of velanor it is an elf you
don't have to think along about the
picture where the figure is leaning on a
big hammer at the latest in combination
with the red beard and the golden dust
on the fingers it is clear that we are
dealing with a representative of the
dwarves a third picture raises more
questions because we see the staff of a
wizard which is supposed to represent a
broken sword if this is really a wizard
one wonders how he made it into the
second age after all they didn't
actually appear until the third age the
same applies to the figure with a scale
armor and the sword with a horus hand
here one immediately thinks of a warrior
from rohan although the realm did not
emerge until thousands of years later
last but not least a closer look reveals
a person with spy gloves and the sword
of sauron you can probably guess who
that could be furthermore some more
pictures were published shortly after
showing impressions of the new actors of
elrond and galadriel as well as some new
characters developed for the series
furthermore there are some behind the
scenes pictures which is definitely make
you want to see more
last sunday on the occasion of the 56th
super bowl there was finally a first
trailer to see because amazon in
competition with disney and netflix of
course did not miss the opportunity to
show the first scenes of their upcoming
the lord of the rings series finally
we'll give you some background
information that will surely make you
enjoy the new trailer even more first we
see footage of the island kingdom of
numenor as well as the voice of a young
girl who turns out to be a
representative of the so-called harfoots
played by michaela cavanaugh these are
one of the three original hobbit tribes
and even the largest in terms of numbers
subsequently it becomes clear that
during the series we will get to know
many places that have not yet made it to
the movie screen the characters that are
now seen are called nomadic hunters and
look quite like vampires with bad luck
wings are these possibly remnants of a
race from the first age we also see
gladriel played by morphet clark in
moving pictures for the first time she
seems to be quite reckless for example
fighting riding or even climbing in one
scene we also see her with a new
character a forest elf named aaron dear
in fact his appearance did not cause
enthusiasm everywhere as the dark skin
color of the puerto rican actor is very
much at odds with tolkien's original
conception of the elves well certainly a
debatable decision for tolkien's
hardliners in general the trailer
bristles with short fast cut scenes that
feature a monster-like creature
alongside flaming arrows and presumably
the elf celebrant boar actor owen arthur
plays prince durian iv a friendly
looking dwarf and son of during the
third king of gaza doom also known to
many as morion slowly we approach the
end of the trailer and can catch a
glimpse of a young elrond kneeling next
to a large rock and the dwarf princess
diese in the next scene we must look
very closely because we briefly see two
male characters one of whom seems to be
naked the inferno around them strongly
reminds us of mount doom in the
northwest of mordor and many speculate
that sauron can be seen here the trailer
finally ends with two dirty hands
touching which of course rolls out the
involvement of the extremely clean elves
left hand could be from the mysteries
tom bombadil being somewhere between
hobbits and humans his origin is a
mystery through and through he says of
himself in the first of the lord of the
rings books that he is older than any
creature in the world all in all this
super bowl gave us some great
impressions of the series the makers
didn't shy away from using a lot of cgi
which might not be to the liking of some
fans
that's it again with our latest original
we hope you're now up to date on the
latest developments and perhaps even a
bit more anticipation for the amazon
series than after watching the trailer
amazon's mega project the lord of the
rings the rings of power will be
released this late summer on september
2nd 2022 exclusively on prime video
[Music]
you